hola como estan mi nombre es claudia
cerramiento y trabajo para madison
community services en el día de hoy
quisiera compartir con ustedes
información acerca de madison community
servicios y un nuevo programa ofrecido
para las personas de habla hispana y el
programa llamado nuevas raíces news
ahora hablemos un poquito de new roots
qué es
es importante y dulce es un programa
nuevo está creado para darle servicio en
las personas de habla hispana pero
específicamente a las personas que han
pedido refugio y están esperando por la
decisión porque ni rusia está sirviendo
a las personas que están esperando por
refugio o que son cosas que han sido
aceptadas pero están enfrentando
dificultades o también a las personas
que consideramos que están vulnerables
new roots ha sido creado para prestarles
un apoyo emocional porque está
comprobado que cuando están esperando
la respuesta la salud mental se ve
afectada y precisamente porque son
personas que lo que tienen es un riesgo
de klein no tienen acceso en la
comunidad a muchos servicios in your
room se está tratando de cubrir esa
parte ofreciendo los servicios de case
management grupos de apoyo y actividades
sociales
para acceder a los servicios de new
roots no se necesita ir a hacerlo a
través de la anses pues puede ser una
organización que haga que federal del
cliente o la persona
ella misma o él mismo puede llamarlos y
decir que le gustaría registrarse en
nuestro programa
con esto les ha hablado un poquito de
madison y rush también mar y son tiene
el rais program que es recovery durante
él
el asentamiento y el proceso de
inmigración el drive program ofrecido a
personas que son permanentes residentes
o protestas persona
este programa es ofrecido en diferentes
lenguas árabe farsi y otras lenguas
la new roots es la expansión de raíz y
también la expansión del his panes pro
el énfasis en new roots ahora mismo
porque tenemos la llegada de muchas
personas que están aplicados por refugio
y están esperando su respuesta y sabemos
que están un poco tristes
tal vez deprimidos frustrados y la
intención de new roots es brindarles el
apoyo en el momento que lo necesitan yo
espero que ésta
información sea productiva para ustedes
si tienen alguna pregunta por favor
comuníquense con madison community
services
mi nombre es claudia sarmiento y soy el
que es management and manager at new
roots muchas gracias